can we get to this get to this lobe
segment
[Music]
I discovered this woman who I call Loeb
in April
the AI reproduced her more easily than
most celebrities her presence is
persistent and she haunts every image
she touches
uh
what's CW
content warning oh take a seat this is a
true horror story and veers sharply
macabre
foreign
what does that mean you're the one who
went to Duke you should be able to
pronounce that you know what that word
means [ __ ] no what is macabre mean I
don't know dude can we get a can we get
a definition on Macabre it's Macabre
it's just Macabre yeah ooh a silent Ray
I like that
what is it disturbing and horrifying
because of involvement with
uh a depiction of death an injury okay
cool
I like this already a Cobb and this is
her right there Globe okay
I don't know man she just kind of looks
like Joaquin Phoenix scroll up scroll up
yeah zoom into those okay maybe not
Joaquin but
oh this is it doesn't get worse so yeah
what's what's the story here so
uh I'll explain negative prompt weights
in case you don't know with these
instead of creating an image of the text
prompt the AI tries to make the image
look as different from the prompt as
possible this logo was the result of the
negatively weighted prompt Brando
okay that's kind of sick so they typed
in Brando and the AI tried to make the
opposite of Brando yeah okay I wondered
is the opposite of that logo in turn
going to be a picture of Marlon Brando I
typed uh whatever that is as a prompt I
received these off-putting images all of
the same devastated looking older woman
with defined triangles of
uh yeah rosacea on her cheeks
okay
this is starting to get creepy uh my
friend made this image of a hyper
compressed glass tunnel surrounded by
angels in the style of West Anderson I
instantly combined this image with the
original image of Loeb in an image
prompt without text for reasons we can't
fully explain nightmare is ensued
I'm not feeling that nightmarish you
don't you don't find her creepy not
really
through some kind of emergent
statistical accident something about
this woman is adjacent to extremely gory
and macabre
no go ahead go ahead
okay hit it again hit it again now go
ahead go ahead go ahead you got it you
got it Macabre yeah imagery and the
distribution of the ai's World Knowledge
I feel like McConaughey could say
Macabre and everyone would be like so
sexy yeah yeah
Macabre oh [ __ ] that's starting to
oh
yeah that's starting to tickle a little
bit
since lobe was discovered using negative
front waves weights
uh her Gestalt
what the [ __ ] who is this guy
this [ __ ] trying to really use
his degree what does Gestalt mean an
organized hole that is perceived as more
than the sum of its parts
okay organized hole
organized hole
right so your mom
foreign
of traits that are equally far away from
something but our combined trains are
still a cohesive concept uh for the AI
yeah whatever who cares man
okay so that this to me looks like a fan
rendition of the hereditary poster yeah
and go to the left
that's [ __ ] up that's uncomfortable
horrifying that's uncomfortable that
sucks if that thing started talking then
I would okay extreme gold extreme Gore
warning the angel hallway plus lobe also
produced art with such copious Gore that
probably very few people went to see
them but here are two I don't feel
comfortable posting the most disturbing
ones borderline snuff images of
dismembered screaming children oh God
it's pretty intense so how are they
getting these are they just
are they are they writing that same
phrase and doing the reverse prompt to
get her yeah and then maybe it's like
combining other images into the AI so
whatever the short of it is this AI is
producing these gory ass images of Loeb
which are yeah pretty creepy is there
more after this what the artist is
trying to do is get rid of low by
combining new images and they can't get
rid of like it just keeps appearing in
every image I see it's just like creepy
because Loeb keeps returning
and they're trying to make the images
like less gory and they're are they're
just like getting more and more horrific
with random images so it's kind of
become an internet Creepypasta how she
haunts these images okay this [ __ ] is
changing so fast the [ __ ] world is
just no no look at me
Amazon Studios nice [ __ ] try for
whatever dumb movie you're trying to
promote nice try we know what the [ __ ]
you're doing when low it was on Amazon
Amazon you know no it's Amazon Studios
presents Macabre yeah yeah yeah
when Macabre drops on streaming
everywhere on October 31st
I'm gonna put my whole foot down and
watch it now this somehow is PR for
don't worry darling that's what it is
yeah and weirdly Harry Styles is in the
background
Christmas
what's this one this one Harry spits and
loeb's mouth
here's lobus Kirby
huh that one's kind of cool actually
I don't know it kind of looks like ice
cream I'd eat it yeah it looks tasty
that's what I was just saying
it looks like a giant gumball on his
nose oh that this one here's lobe as a
bee
it looks like Lopez
doesn't look like you guys
[ __ ] assaulted by bees
you've gone down I kind of love Loeb
I love lobe yeah I love her
[Music]
hello hello
even when her red cheeks are in front of
his globeness
this is comedy right yeah this has to be
a bit
I love the Lord
it reminds me she haunts the images
persists through generations and
overpowers other bits of the prompt
because the AI so easily optimizes
towards her face okay dude this is a
problem with these like AI creation
things it's giving people with no social
sphere
way too much meaning in their life yeah
just projecting a connection to like a
random AI thing gotcha yeah
don't stop doing this to me yeah
typing in girl with weird face
Loeb
with sick cams yeah
anime lobe giant breast
[Laughter]
the amount of big titty anime girl dudes
on since you said that and since I
started using mid-journey seriously it's
so funny I think it's the best thing
that they could have done is leave it
open on Discord for you to see other
people's prompts yeah
because also other people are looking at
mine like what you're maybe co-animated
why the [ __ ] would you want that why are
you making art dude cute anime girl blue
eyes brown hair the horniness is off the
charts bruh okay
so that's her and Avatar
sexy lobe big lobe
nice big Globe boobs yeah
I started going insane at this point uh
I had hundreds of other hundreds of lobe
images and I'm starting to combine her
with three just don't do the prompt yeah
then they won't do it yeah just type
pretty easy just type in race car bed it
all goes away every time I type in lobe
it does the image of her yeah no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] that's what it's built to do
this guy has got to get some friends yet
Dutch grass yeah keep going down
descendants of the lobe lineage I hate
this man
I love this [ __ ] though no the AI Art Is
Awesome it is [ __ ] awesome I was just
unlocking this entire new world of
Storytelling you know yeah oh I love it
I love it